Okay, so the next topic we have is how we all are going to be working together.
And the major points we wanted to cover was your availability, modes, communication, onboarding, and…
the documentation resources that we should have.
So, availability, I think, this lot kind of works really empower us.
Because that's when the RFP is looking really good, so…
Okay. Those days around this time, if initial was sent.
And very quickly, I think we all available on the instill as well.
So if you ever have to ask something about organizers.
And, um, for multiple community initiatives in theaters, depending on those of them.
what individuals are in April.
500 pounds for the eggs.
You want to have, I don't recommend that extended for something done.
I will not for the onboarding process, it's pretty open, which is, uh…
We'd, um, give you access to whatever you need for our initial public, either the DIMS application or, um,
In the 80s and resources, somehow the DRM was starting to miss parts of the perfect program.
and maybe Tesla today will almost nothing.
Anyhow, as we have.
Yeah, so probably we'll ask you guys to, uh, in this annual conference partner up.
I didn't give it to come back to me by itself.
They don't do that, right? So we're just asking the items at the product, or they have those.
And you can just upload your outdoor systems so that you have access to, like, use that to the other things.
And as we grow… as we grow about the project, we give you more and more accessibility.
Because it's not a long process at these regards, so as long as you bring the, um, GA code even,
Um, you would need to have assistance with that.
But also please include the mentors and access on Teams.
Yeah, 100%.
Well, have we now done that, actually. No, no, they're able to do that. Yeah, you should. Yeah.
We'd like to know what you guys are talking about before.
I want… I want the team to promise the moon.
I also wanted to ask about the documentation, um, with that, uh, like, uh, which…
opportunity ideas, um,
You know, could have access to the previous DEANS documentation really depends. It might be useful for them to understand that.
We can share that perspective.
Okay.
We didn't know where we've been, but…
final onboarding route, so we can be set with those.
So, just in case you want to ask. But you've changed things since then? Yeah. Yeah, we've not so much changed so much and added. We've added a lot of times, but yeah, we should make sure that fucked up the new play.
At least, yeah. Let's make sure…
That'd be up here for a bit, yeah.
Um, next to the project purpose and background.
Uh, from your guys' point of view, the motivation benefits, stakeholder,
of the feature you try to build.
Hey guys. Um, so, with the moderation of it, it's mainly to, I think,
get the process of getting the initial routing data.
in a good liable manner out of the system. That segment is an even better.
Um, because I think right now,
The only way we can probably do that better is by just getting more weaker and…
They'll be having more, we can look at the data and understanding.
Which is not the way to go about it, because that's not speaking the music.
Just really throwing that forth.
running both computers and bills.
Anything I want to add that to you? Yeah, um, just… there's a lot… it's a very human process right now to, like,
one vendor sends something one format, another vendor sends something another format.
teams of people have to go through and interpret it, and then try and…
gram, whatever that is, into the existing structure, or, like, attributes or ways of looking.
And, uh, just that process. We'd like to make that a lot more hands-off, where they can just upload something,
It'll get it in there, and then they can do future modification, maybe it's not right or wrong, but just getting it in there in the first place takes so much time right now.
No? All good, all good, thank you.
And then… and then once thin, making it as robust as possible, so…
throwing out all of the attributes that a particular product might have, be that by a spray thing with EDFs, or scraping a vendor website, or whatever we need to do with the product.
entrance.
is kind of step two in our sense, and then step three is meetings.
Um, I forget what he followed it, but it was, like, um, a man in the middle kind of concept for female balloon. Yeah, that's it.
Uh, they simply went on the root concept where, yeah, we'll do as much as we can, and we'll probably need some approval on that and whatnot.
But then also, like, what needs updated? What, um, can we already score products so that we see, like, how many product is that we can…
pull up a download of products, ladies, like, all of these are, like, you know, 20% down and they only work.
I'm curious, what is the frequency of new vendors coming on board? Do you have to just booked in this?
I imagine it's very enormous for the history is.
Yeah, we're open to increase this more and more public new product that we're launching, uh, is named at the small to medium-sized business market.
Alright, so most of our lives right now are, like, enterprise clients, so…
For them, we're always onboarding and more vendors, but it's not, like, 100% where they've got them yet.
or hopefully in the future, and will be.
Um, but a lot of that's gonna be overlap, so that…
Vendor A sells, right,
Apple, uh, and the vendor B also sells Apple.
Well, we need to make a good catalog by Apple devices, and then be able to link them up via vendors, and add on the original vendor attributes in there.
Part of that is just how things are remote when they were being built.
We need to make sure that all the attributes that it means.
We did a portal in the intervention as possible.
And we don't…
Do you have any, uh…
Oh, go ahead.
I was gonna say, do you have any…
data around…
I guess two things. One is how accurate humans are at this endeavor.
And the second is…
Um, if you think about the, you know, the total sort of workflow, I don't know what your workflow is, but I can imagine, you know,
looking at the data, entering it, someone else verifying it, like,
Where the, you know, analysis of
how much time is spent on those different…
activities within that work, uh, workflow.
No, I was just gonna say, we are currently actually relaunching gyms to production now.
So, all the workflows that we've done are on the legacy Power Mainbook systems. Number 7 slower.
Um, so I don't have been efforts to start with a month on either date.
Um, we, now that the PIMS is launching, we did start beforeting that as the current state.
Uh, so that we can see how much better we are at the end of the year.
Then, uh, what was the first part of that question, too? It was something about…
Um, what… how accurate are humans at this activity?
Um, I mean, I guess…
we could use those metrics, um…
Oh, no, I don't know if we have how accurate, like, we could easily show how to do better before. Yeah, like, what a good end…
goal of it is based on, like, the PDF we took at the beginning, but for accuracy, that's a good question.
I swore I was going to see was, uh, we could surely connect that information and send it, or send it across to you.
Uh, we're just coming back to active in the middle of the night, I suppose.
I don't know if the team's gonna need it, but just… these are just, like, things that, hey, I'm interested, I'm curious.
Do you have, like, some metrics to see where people were on process and free. So I guess the one question would be, even just the data that you've got it there,
Are there, uh, teacher reports to say the data's inaccurate? Do you have information like that, or…?
you know, how do you discover that? It's usually word of mouth, or, uh, yeah, the people using our site, or the catalog team will notice something, and then they'll go in and change that, or our salespeople will, in talking to customers, realize something's wrong or not acting, or they're missing.
Where we can work for it, what product there's…
misinformation, I would like to.
But you have no central line employees, including that. The bigger problem now, at least probably, as we had…
new suppliers for our interest compliance. It's pretty easy to get a part and a price in there.
Um, it actually meet all the attributes.
Um, we're not doing it a lot of the time, um, because it's just too much effort.
perhaps to spend on all of the new product lines that we have it.
Um, but for the end user, of course, it would be very helpful to have the document piece.
Um, so, for the sake of getting it up and running, and it works, and they can technically buy it,
Not having them is fine, and that's what everybody will.
But we're looking at how can we get that battery user experience with more data.
We'll do some background context, too, into, like, the… just the attributes in general, um,
We… we have a lot of attributes. The catalog team, really, the majority of their time is looking at more attributes and coming up with
coming up with different ways to classify things, so…
We're especially in the building controls industry.
Um, like, um…
There's not one in this group, but, like, a valve for a pipe, like, in the bathroom or something like that. Like, they want to know
what material it is, what the pressure rating is, the heat resistance rating, like, we… it's really driven in that industry.
is when they're going to look up parts, they don't really care about the brand, they just want to be able to filter by, I need this rating, I need at least to handle this pressure.
He's been hit and handle this temperature range, automatic draw, like normal and closed, like, uh…
It's really around the attributes, as opposed to where we've been making the iPhone, but that's…
That's a little more, like, you know you want an iPhone when you go. This was more like, you don't care what brand it is. You know you need 16 gigs on your phone or 8GB, like, 5G. Yeah.
So the thinking is, for each type of product category, a human is already doing this, and we probably could be making, like, this category of products needs this set of routes.
So then when you're trying to ingest the product,
First, we have to try to figure out how we were getting there. This fire had probably noticed something close on that, meaning they matched up ours.
Uh, and then the second step is…
Okay, now I know a category is, it needs all these attributes highlighted instead.
to the venture, sometimes supply sheets, or… Yes, yes. And do you link?
parts of the spec sheets or not?
Yep, yeah, we have a lot of part-flowing inspections today, um, but again, the challenge with new parts, like,
Ideally, the vendor is giving us a link to a spec sheet, but then giving us the product.
And that can be helpful to you guys. We can kind of pull that spec sheet under our own control and work off of it.
Alrighty. It's always going to be that easy.
But in the best-case scenario, they do. And sometimes we don't, though, and the catalog team is literally goes out to their websites or lipsticks, they can go online and tries to infer and then put that in.
I think you also mentioned in the presentation before that, uh, some vendors
Um, give you guys some catalog, like a physical catalogs, or like, so the catalog team has to, like, manually enter all the data from that?
And as a part of this, we'll want to automate that as well, right? Like, a way to…
Yeah, so it's not so… it used to be that we'd get, like, a book, um, and they would try to, like, enter as much as we could. We're not dealing with that anymore, but they still might get if they can get it, right? Like…
But more often than not, we'll then be able to give us something individually, some sort of Excel spreadsheet or whatever.
Um, so that's the bulk of what we're trying to focus on. Good question. How structured and structured the data is? Yeah.
Yeah. If there are…
kind of, like, an ideal…
layout of a farm that I have in mind for each part, like,
Uh, actually, I'll start holding it.
Sure, I really have one toothpaste both.
Yeah, there's definitely, like, a basic schema if you lower, like, it needs a…
product number, which is, like, um…
what you refer to it as the name of the product, and then we have
supplier product number, sometimes, like, suppliers have their own, uh, way that they, like, label a product versus what they sell to the public.
Couple more fields, like description, list, cost, uh…
But after that, the rest is all gets into attributes and just kind of more, like,
things associated with it. Yeah, and that's what I'm saying, a human can say, like, what category is tablets, right? So, like,
what's the screen size of the tablet? Is it, like, pen enabled? What, uh, what, like, um, standard of pen devices with this tablet use?
Um, what colorism, of course, like, like, leaders, obviously brand this kind of separate thing, but
When you keep going on and on, the human… we can have humans to find, like, tablets and mingles upon things.
And then what's kind of, you gotta just figure out how they did those funny things from the, like,
whatever we're given from the vendors, and work them into, like, what we want them to do with.
I didn't mean I'm sitting there needing more data actually shows that.
We do have, like, a cat meeting and an annual meeting, where we have
Our attitudes map the latest products within Admin, and just take it with them and see it in the 48 minutes. So that's… so that way becomes the slowest, and… Yeah, so, like, with the tablets, Jared just listed some, like, you know, we would have the category of tablets
And then we would have attributes assigned to that, so all tablets should have the attribute of screen size. All tablets should have the attribute of pen enabled.
And then as we upload a new product into the tablet category, we automatically know, okay, it needs a value for string size, it needs a value for preventative, right? Like, so we have
the value that the product has, um, at least downstream of us, like, before that, um, matching an attribute to a category, and then everything in the category.
has to have values by no dashes. Very good.
And that gets back to what I was saying earlier, like, the third part, uh, which is saying that this product is 20% ready.
we would have a way to kind of do that based on, like, we've only entered two of the ten attributes associated with this
products category, product, we need to know the screen size. We need to enter a screen size. That could be a way to determine what implementation mechanism is.
We're not always doing this step. We could also bring 3 at least
when you set up the spot for kicking each other out of absolutely needed to be able to make a sick kindness product.
It would be nice to have them, but
Again, we have these four things.
Is there… I know before we talked about the most sensitive trend from the vendor with pricing, is there any proportion
information about a product that makes it
more sensitive or not, are we influencing the newest thing?
And so there was the very same idea here. One or two brands that are a little…
products, so, uh…
Yeah, it's just a matter of, like, we can actually sell their products.
You can still go on their website if they answer the most of our website.
Um, so the only thing we really concerned about Goofy and Friday was…
from the looks of it that I think we'll have to have discussions with the catalogue team just to understand how exactly they, like,
social information, so we can do the same thing, just
an automated fashion. So, like, we'll have…
access to them, like you said, you can make some teams, or…
love to… we can come over to EPAS as well for meeting them in person.
And we could catalog team with the parts catalog team.
We can probably, like… you would be able to message, like, the catalog work that we have at eParts, our parent company, Office Control Trolls, has a much larger, uh, catalog team.
Which we… where we get most of them. We could organize information. No, with them, that would probably be, yeah, something in person would be ideal. But with the eParts catalog person, yeah, you could feel free to reach out to them on Teams.
most of it. I don't think that was catalog work, so…
We do some… like I said, we don't worry about the attributes as much.
dispensary one or two people in our movement does catalog at all, and they also do other things.
And they're gonna be… it was still only, like, 4 people, but they're all actually dedicating to catalogness.
And they are Alps is a e-commerce, like, distributor that they're building control schools.
So they are highly incentivized to make bread power dynamic, so that they're helping their customer enjoy the right thing because they bought the library instead of someone else.
Most of our customers, it's the tools where
Um, the engineer needs to, you know, they're, like, kind of locked in using our platform for corporate or whatever.
Um, so, it's like, okay to not have the best catalog data, but we don't want
Phelps needs to be able to have to make it better.
Did you guys keep track from places, though, somebody orders something and turns out to prolonged things?
Um, I think we'll have that now, figuring a CEC on…
Right. Yeah, and we could do a lot of inserting, too, with RMAs. You could match RMAs against them. We don't have the structure for, you know, experimenting with me, so…
Okay.
Uh, I think, uh…
Can we touch up on the… like, we had an ML component to the project? I was just a bit curious about…
Uh, it said that we have to, like, you know, for future also, we plan to use
enable further operations, how, like, which all aspects are you planning to use machine learning in?
confidence scores and other things.
So, financial scores would be available to a part where, uh…
So, uh, pink remains, uh, you guys will be ready.
Uh, in certain activities, and you should be able to grab these attributes. So, basically, right?
We could be able to do things like face-to-face sampling and then figure out what would be the appropriate attribute for this testing.
But it's just… it's just mattering, and it's also a little bit of, uh…
This is just gone.
what could be that event for this specific feeling. That's also in terms of figuring it out in what activities we can use.
So, um, that's kind of the main thing. So, when we do make these predicates for these specific academies, we do assignments, but
And that's where the confidence score comes in.
Where you see the conference code is a little bit more important. Exactly.
So, then the system learned that…
this particular… this is the automatically corrected button. So that's… that's the next step, right? So…
You actually have your booth, and then, you know, as you…
As you keep getting more and more of similar errors.
You can attach another part of the system, which kind of rectifies itself, or you can still try and do that if it's goodnight.
So it all depends on how the project was, how it kind of turns out, again, how it develops, you know.
Terral, they actually expect travel breeds are yield examples of photograph with a 3G rendering, and…
from this series, those symptoms extend just beyond fetch Tools 30.
attribute. We will have… then use it.
product pictures, yeah, but I don't think anything that would be an actual big phone or an attribute of Stonehenge.
Yeah, they wouldn't be, like, the Actives and just explain things.
So, you guys just mentioned that you have the practical one who had, like, a schema of attributes, right? So if the attributes is the fixed part of it,
Why are we applying the ML to the first part? Like, why do we need a confidence score to be assigned to BRIS? Like, why not to the category because
That's what is a variable thing, uh, right?
I mean, it could be for weeks, eh? So, those buttons…
You've been trying that in the academy product, which could be contains both on the other machine learning.
Next is, once you do figure that out and go to bed and we'll start things.
Uh, you would know a specific, um, so for example, if I say,
a specific attribute, for example,
they take the pressure of the process immediately of the water or something like that. Like, for example, if it's a 30-kilo basket, then…
Um, what we assign is actually, uh, something like 20 seconds in a row.
Instead, so that would be strongly at the root and the document store.
So, it might not know the exact kind of, uh…
You need to put in there, value to put in there. It could be… it could just confuse that, uh…
Um, I mean, I think as we have, like, this internally,
module-based, which kind of purpose.
lowest pathetic values, but you're painting in close to the distinction of a gain basket or leave architects of the individual towards January.
then you would have to be already doing validations for that.
So that, you know, okay, these certain values and the exact sort of values you're looking at, because they might not be enough data to actually implement… But then, your, uh, the values that we're talking about, uh, do I, like,
You mentioned the sped dog, right? So…
words can only tell you exactly? Um…
Again, so it's not going to put you right…
let's say it this way, uh, different suppliers will provide different sets of athletes. Apple might fall screen size, screen size.
And someone else might holler at, um…
And sometimes it's not that cut and dry, either. Sometimes it's not just string-sized
stories are. Sometimes it's like,
Um, the gas flow rate versus the water flow rate versus, like,
There is some interpretation we've done between the buyers to be able to match them up to a similar standard.
Two years to Barnes have ever stopped check their data? I mean, it's very feedback loop there and then.
Uh, on the outside, they knew sometimes, um, that, um…
On our side, we have an experience that some of our…
Alright, take a little break, if…
So, so the manual process right now, I mean thrives and we get the supplier to tell us our alpha meeting style.
Um, so we deal with them, and it was a spreadsheet that describes the attributes that we want for these products.
There's a lot of manual effort for them to actually build her out, and a lot of them just don't.
Um, so they have the opportunity to try to make it right, but it's people with them for either gotten through.
Thereabouts. Leading us to the question, but was it ever the other way down? Would they come up and tell you that, okay, this is how…
We want to build product to be, you know, capitalized, so these are the attributes that, uh, and then…
What I mean to ask is, uh, let's say the iPad. In your system, you just have 4.
But then, since they know the internet working, maybe, like, I'm just saying, are they like, okay, I need a first one.
So, were there a requirement?
So, so first off, we can totally take up Bitcoin right now.
Um, if they want to add in a particular attribute that isn't in that required step, that's fine. Is that even possible? Like, are they allowed to come up with a requirement that starts?
They are really able to define the data set for a catalog.
Uh, because… so they have their own definition, right? They have their own analog somewhere, and some days are they…
Um, some of them can give us a lot of that pay that some of them can't, but…
Um, uh, our job is to homogenize data between the manufacturers.
So, we… we have to have the liberty to be able to change the modifier that begins with it. It's for the same ease of use for the actual application.
But also, some of the vendors could want, um, more so in the case of, like, ELPS.
Um, they could want their products to get more visibility to customers. They would want their products to show up in more searches based on more attributes, and especially when they're working out, like, the deal of
the price they're going to be giving to buy it from them. There's, like, all these negotiations, and a lot of times they will…
actually look at their catalog at ELPS and see, like, hey, this is the way we're… you're showing our products to, like,
something right there.
Okay, we go, next part.
of your experience with the previous two-year project that you guys have sponsored.
any, uh, like, just about the previous experience, any do's and don'ts that you have for us?
usually the mind.
Yeah, um, dues, um, reach out to us on Teams, like, as much as possible. Like, we do not want getting, like, a lot of communication, a lot of messages, a lot of posts, like, we prefer that rather than, um…
Yeah, we're, like, saving it all for the next week's meeting. Like, if something comes up like that, just reach out. It's, you know, we're all very, uh…
We have very fast communications.
So I'd say that's a big one.
We're like, very briefly in the presentation, mentioned it, but we… we were like, this idea of after our January debate.
Um, so, like, that's because we're saying something needs to be submari, doesn't mean… like, you're already doing it, something that's great, but with this bad, you know.
We'll be glad to think of it differently, or explain why we should think of it differently with, like, I'd rather have that discussion than later.
We'll never take offense to you.
Thinking about a different way, that would be it.
is probably fine. Yeah, yeah, that's very helpful.
I would say, like, asking the same question again and again is still fine. That will not ask me what you do.
It kind of helps in clear the gap, and it keeps the homeless for the visual openness.
Also, um, I'd say, too, um,
follow up with us, like, if you…
If we commit to something in a meeting, um, and you haven't heard much from us, like,
quote-unquote, bother us. Like, reach out to me, like, hey, you know, like, I haven't heard back with this. Like, again, we want that.
As opposed to then we get to the next week's meeting, and he, oh, did you get a chance to do that when you forgot about it all week, or something, you know?
any particular don'ts that you guys think?
You should be mindful of?
Kind of covered it in between the side. Probably, uh, just don't go paperwork provider, and then just, uh, proper two weeks later and everything else.
I mean, we completely privilege that, too, but…
It'd just be a bit more easier for us to keep track of things that help you guys are programming.
Yeah, I think that's the main one, and Matt, you've had pretty successful project right now. It's just that, I mean,
don't miss bad, like, saying it takes me longer time to move onboard that.
And you do a map like your studies and academics, that's what would be amazing.
It might be difficult to stay that invited. I would say if, like,
are random 2A, and we pay for something, and you send it. You have to say something?
is send that to us, we'll take you look at it for a long time, but we'll still be taking time.
if it won't be productiveness at that point, so…
Yeah, you certainly know me, because this semester, they only have 4 barns a week to work on this, but they have zero intent for doing that, too, which one of those kind of thing.
summer time around for a very good thing.
How many of you have it done? Two or three, I don't remember how many people did 3. Okay, this is our fourth.
That's good, yeah, it's good to be the experience. I mean, when you get a new client who's never had any experience with those things,
They think, oh, the team is fully working for us 24-7.
That other thing, not only important to note.
to your point, we're getting… we're getting better and better every year with how we're interfacing.
Well, a lot of it's about managing expectations, yes, for most of it.
I'm gonna put words in the team's mouth, which is, you know, this is a lot of good experience and do's and don'ts.
From the team's… I'll actually ask the team, from the team's perspective, is there anything that you want from
from eParts, and how you work with them.
Have you thought about that?
I think from my point of view, it was just the communication part, like,
We are bound to have a lot of questions, because it's going to be a kind of a…
struggling with scratch point of view, so we'll have questions.
And if, like, you guys can respond, like, that'll be… I think that's the main thing I have in mind.
And that you already cared of, so that's really good.
Elizabeth our third, uh, product data related.
Uh, it's a new project.
So, sometimes, like for me, sometimes it'll be hard to remember what I've shared with you versus, like, the other teams.
So I'll always ask clarifying questions. Don't be afraid.
Well, also, I guess, uh, I guess one thing, too, just to do in previous experience that we…
We've had before, especially, like, with the initial PIMS, we had
months of actually just kind of circling back to the initial kind of same question, with a lot of confusion, they weren't getting it. It's a very complex
distribution model. We won't really get into the distribution between our tenants, but my main point is, like, uh…
There's, like, something you're still unclear on overall, like, we can keep revisiting it. We found that if we get a really, really concrete understanding of that.
Even if it takes a couple weeks, I'm touching on them every week, but it's gonna definitely be better in any of them.
Yeah, it's important to have domain knowledge from the team's perspective for that.
Moving on to the next part.
So, now we have the product usage.
I think we've already touched up a bit on this, but…
Uh, the industry pipeline, I don't be a different, uh, like, client interface, or…
How are we trying to, like, do we get to plan something that they can…
share the data with, or just the PDF they already submit, and we just process it on our side.
authorization pipeline.
Yeah, from the Southern, yeah.
Um, I mean…
We either want to set, like, harder environments on this.
Uh, we mean, right now, one of these files, we're getting, like,
by emailing with the vendor,
Uh, sometimes it would be big enough that I think Brian, who runs weekly or something that he set up to put them on his own.
Um, you know, the best…
The best long-term reading on this is to make it as often as possible, just like a February 9 days.
One of the means that might be DBI, one of them means is going to be where they have some B.
Uh, but it could… I don't want to limit it, but it could be, like,
setting up a way for them to see this, and I think that's been corrected into our system.
I don't want to say there's absolutely no vendor interface here. They took one of the best users to clean up.
some of that, uh, given them loose type from state perspective is making.
Um, so it just…
Depends, uh, on kind of our mutual, uh, exploration of the problem.
so many vendors who are giving us data, I don't…
Obviously, I have some business requirements with the company, right? So why wouldn't we have a sanitized portal?
Like, the… some people get written in CBA form, and then some send it over an email or via
So, why… why not a single format like this, or where people just feed in where
our data, and then we take it forward from you guys. That's the ultimate goal, and we originally had that with Tim at the very beginning,
In addition to the plan… in addition to the catalog teams.
vendors themselves could come in here, and they could do the work themselves.
Uh, we'll… we'll be working on some of the efforts this year, too. So there's… there's, like, the historical reason as to why we haven't… I'm not in the past. Um, but kind of one maintenance team, uh, historically has been very, um,
Um, like, they want to fully own the data that gets in the system, they don't want anyone else's fingerprints on it besides their own.
within the vendors. Um, so it was a very intentional way to manual for a long time.
Now, reverse cleared up for our own desire to begin pension board manual.
Um, so yes, we are trying to answer questions like that. We'll stop break for waiting.
Basically, one of the interesting experiments or research would be
to take some data that… data sets you've had before,
And, uh, sample data sets, we compare them to what's in PIMS now, or whatever.
just to see how they kind of map out
And see where the gaps are hopefully being in crypto thing dealing with that.
But also give them an idea that familiar with.
We're not answering the questions.
Um, yeah, about the product vision, I think we also touched up on that.
you know, particularly light about it.
Uh, yeah, we can maybe… we can talk about the team responsibility and deliver those a bit.
So, as, uh…
as a deliverable, it's just going to be a system, right, where…
Uh, we have the, like, engine pipeline with the…
ML model to, uh, read the attributes.
So, okay, is there anything else you want to add on these points?
Um, not just, uh, we wanted also, like, from the application part of that, that actually may search some of, like, the staging was right, and it would do an additional repair and cylinder model.
Um, in Yahoo and in India. It's a system of…
So, they should leave it to be enough of these sources.
probably churn out some sort of, uh,
Prediction 30 is programmed at 8.
a programmatic approach to just put these things into the right type of games.
Uh, and they're probably paying attention to the developer. I think that's… that's the problem.
Yeah, we want that, uh, that actually… the model, but then also…
something that puts what the model determines at least in these tables. We do have staging environment domain, so we just have to believe.
I still… I'm done for the day in the name.
And then probably the community, and then we'll get the final table, which is probably to fill out.
We already have a…
the quick… our schema right now, basically, like, for the prob… we have, like, product table,
But for every product options table, product attributes table, but for every table we have, we also have a…
staging product table, the staging product options table, a staging product attribution table. And these tables, that combination is how we have interfaces where almost like a Git difference. They can see, like, this is the product before, and then these are the changes I'm making, and this is where they've been approved, or…
decide, no, that's not right, and they go back and change something again.
Ideally, we would just need the model, if you would like upload spec sheets to just pop it into the stating table, and then from there, Pint handles it in the opinion.
see the differences, they can choose to go manually, edit more things, or whatnot, but um…
Yeah, does that make sense?
I'm curious, for the previous Studio Teams workflow, will they ever… did they ever do this exercise of doing the statement award?
A requirements documents? We've gone through a requirements document.
Um, any other possible constraints or risks?
That would, like, we should take a keep mind while developing.
Uh, without data sensitivity or something on that same.
prices, so…
just to be looking at NIV data, we should be able to edit.
Where it was something I was expecting.
If you can reactivate, and uh…
I think…
We need this test if we don't just put it all the time.
Um, understanding the exact scope thing we need to show that.
be kind of adjusted for the manual, you just…
I think that's what it is.
Okay, next is, um, about AI usage.
Uh, I just want to ask, like, how do you guys…
use AI today in, like, everyday development, or…
Around the company, where we do. For development, especially for coding, we've been pretty…
Pretty all-in versus February, since by doing… I mean, but 5.30 when I started getting people in the public eye, and we leave it a lot.
Please pursue pretty extensively for all long through.
Of course, all got me expanding well.
I think the third use cases are not doing that in the news.
We kind of…
have the requirements and the state staff that our entities sort of start with the miscellane if they were, and then go building our meeting at the beginning of the week.
I think it's testing heavyweight, so the way you do it is, uh, we generate through it, um, we made sure that we tested expenses and
Um, and then, based on changes,
Again, everything broke.
Okay, and I'm also gonna be, uh, just to my, like, the end, these are, like, you know, we started with all the practice, and we're removed.
With, like, documents inside the code so that it's reading in the future, like, the contacts are better at the text.
We need a couple other things that are important. I mean, we do things with quite complex monitoring for, like, in the groundwork.
For example, if you're working with Facebook features, so you wouldn't need to contact FDM5 application for that.
So, we've had a better room.
Teachers testing are markdown banned.
Agent needed finding out. So, based off of that,
or restrict name demand.
And we're not, um… we use cursor, and we've all kind of… we evaluated Copilot early on, um…
We obviously like Perstart, but we're not restricted to that. Like, if you all decide, do you want to lose cockpit or something, or buy, you know, other tools, like, person from what we already have, that's good for me.
Um, yeah, I wanted to ask if he, for the, like, when we are using AI in our project, like,
Any part you would expect us to use it, like,
generated code and, like, other things, but any other…
Uh, like, your expectation of where we should be using AI.
I mean, I think that's the best experience we can go in.
anticipated for me.
probably just check the course, AMS.
making sure… I mean, even, like, decisions of, uh…
understanding workflow to be direct or something is to please.
I would say it's just the representative available.
That's quick, and for us using those LLMs, would be… should we use ours, or will we be provided one?
from either agriculture subscription that you sell.
Yeah, so within cursory, you can… you can choose for this prompt, I want to use Gemini, or you can switch it, I want to use my signals, like Sonic 4.5.
But, uh, we do need… I think we should be on the phone.
I've been doing it before it really is here.
Okay, so, uh, you mentioned the North Winvestios, like, I've been using anti-mark video, and it seems to be dealing with digital.
Do you not want us to use any other elements. You could, as long as, uh, it's…
keeping the data analysis.
I think… I think as long as the data is not being strife, depending on the run.
Yeah, so yeah, that's the biggest concern. Well, we… other than that, what… Which is the platform look that we need? Yeah. Okay, we knew it was approved for that.
The building of, um,
In first, the product development.
Were that the, uh, from our side, or would that be, uh, from there?
We have open marketplace.
I think it would be, like…
So…
I think a lot of the work that we're going to do with non-party.
one side of the infrastructure team or anything like that.
It was not yet, right? Um, and therefore, for all of that stuff, like, as long as they're deleting directly into the things free throws or anything like that.
I don't mind it being used in that you're having Andy share the stuff for them, right? It kind of doesn't matter that you responded on ours yet. Again, as long as you're not, like,
uploading vendor files to that. Like, I don't want to be… yeah, I don't…
We're not… all the vendor data isn't super sensitive, but also don't want to be just, like, willy willy-nilly with it.
Um, but you're welcome to move your own stuff.
Like, if they decide group lottery looks good, like, I guess we paid for it. That would be kind of absolutely what I was going towards, uh, just from my experience, what our workplace.
Yeah, I don't know what their… any pricing, or is there anything like that. I think a bi-Fi, the Black Friday is, like, the minimum 300 bucks.
There's also not a minimum 200 month to March, so the person.
Uh, so that's… that's part of where my mind is at, but again, if it's a deep flurse, then we have a good rationale for why I should tell you that. No, I… You might not understand that. I do understand that there's something that you're saying that this actually make a 30 times more productive, and there's no way that product appears if they do this to our city.
let's have the discussion.
Having to reach the heads of almost all the weeks to spend a time to stay in academic rational. There are all Asian-based first kind of…
application kind. They all indexed by similarly, they're all numbers with similar model access, familiarity stuffing green.
Yeah, I think it's just a problem. It's exactly, it's just done the level of problems, like, probably kind of have designed me.
You can literally just change the body of the leaders of it.
Yeah.
Likewise decisions, too.
We're a small company, we're not only an enterprise, so it would not make a deal comes to us.
But it also does make the difference to our country grad schools and getting the private schools, like, whatever, so…
Uh, so the money side works on burden.
for us to spend money on this, but…
Thank you, Smart. No problem.
I think next, do you have any…
questions you guys might have, or anyone from the team.
That's having out-of-pind questions.
Yeah, so, uh, I have one, uh…
How do they handouts at the house to understand the testimonies?
It depends on the phone, so, uh, so there are really, like, 3 parts of the pandemic as anybody who is, uh…
the main, um, the data pipeline setting, just locking, uh, and the debaseable location.
For that, we had, like, the proper knowledge transfer from some data after this.
expecting me to try to set things up, and then I just type it on there on books as well.
And then there will be change in brand.
I mean, it was a super lightweight session, but you are spending that, I said.
for other things. We had this kind of, like, documentation hangout.
Where we had the 3-minute talk on important covers, and what's begin with.
So, it depends on your use case.
And what exactly knows. We are looking for more of, like, the stuff that would make lessons, but it stands for them, yes, the blueber hands on them.
Uh, that has allowed the food stock might not be funded, so…
How does your current, uh…
doing the code checking process look like, you know, using our web buffer, and starting from the XFS doc?
ACPRs, who are the stakeholders, then a member of… we should must get approved from?
The bucket is what he knows, and again, I think…
or whatever events that are important to restart the noise can be delivered.
So they were literally in the private approvals and things like that. It should be intuitive. I would say you guys should probably look at the last year.
And that was a few others. Yeah, the only… the only time I could see modifications to, like, something we already have existing is, uh, what we talked about earlier is, like, when it comes time to actually put the products in,
We can talk down the road about how we want to do that, or maybe we just make some APIs that implement or something, I don't know.
Or you could spin off of… spin off the committee if we branch together, and this update stage manual. So that you guys can still upload that report.
And, um, we do also, though, we do use, um, a sonar. Uh, we use… we use sonar for limping.
Todd, you got any third party for, like, security purposes? Like, something like a backup or something?
To check vulnerabilities in the system.
security moving these, uh, so I think someone does it.
So I saw that as pretty, uh, extensive, very, uh, extensive in terms of, uh,
what it covers.
But yeah, it covers anything, so security into almost no checks, too.
I have a trivial question. What were the names of the previous MSD tools? What would their team names be named?
First one of Texas, and then there was, um…
option logic, really unknown with that.
That's alright. We've been in.
Last year, like, did we even have anything? There was, I think it was…
Maybe they never used, I mean, this used eBite's statements.
I mean, you guys should have a new one. That's a rule. Be more fun, learn more. The team name, the scree de Corps. Yeah, the intensity was fun, especially, yeah, but…
And a logo difference, email address.
Uh, there's a decent chance we'll be switching from BitPuck.
in my mind.
We don't have any political conversation.
And you would be our first team using Winning Man.
That would be cycling me for asking the onboarding. So what were your… what was your rationale going from Jira to…
I mean, one of the biggest benefits that I think is fits fast, like, we're gonna open an issue,
is interceptions instead of multiple septants.
And also the flexibility. You can very easily, like, earn something from an issue or test early to… like, it's much more flexible work.
Jira was a lot more, like, locked in with DBA or the portal.
And so it's a great opportunity in the philosophy of the problem. If you were following an aircraft methodologies, it accommodates everything completely with zero tolerance it.
And Bobby just going to… it has… it has support for that. All of these already immunized with…
So… and so it's a little milestone rhythm methodology in general.
everyone having their phones.
Um, a task for transport and class itself.
Any found a date better, or later date with the chance of the energy, and the UI is more technical.
I said, loaded with a commercial product.
raising when it comes to more visibility, that's what we're thinking.
So we know we can show our mentors.
So we're gonna have a standing fund meeting on Thursday, 6 times every week to look at the funds.
I mean, and if there's… if it says tough, uh, just shoot us some other times, uh, we do have a couple reoccurrings on our side that we'll have to… that are kind of like, uh,
No, but other than that, if need be, we can get some more time or something. I mean, based on your schedules, too, I think that's the bigger factor, I think, so…
Aren't this pretty much permitted in today, for sure, and based on you attributes, we can see what else possible in HP has itself.
Obviously, it's domestic, and it's the reason.
I'll let you know, I like to attend them with client meetings. I know Dennis will be able to give up. I always funded. Informative to understand
what is the dialogues back and forth between the findings? Do we start? I'll be exploring the very simple.
Well, during the day after the show.
Well, I wouldn't ask you about an action item review.
Any action item? So, for you guys, this already provide us the access using our annual email IDs and our mentors as well.
And then, um, for any doubts, uh, just restating, uh, the point of contact between Harsha, Jake, and David.
And then, uh, we'll also get access to the teams and the relevant workspaces, like document potions and Intel.
subscription, uh, for the entire team.
And, uh, I mean, not immediately, but then, uh, I guess you would also share details on the current, uh, data accuracy, like, uh, with respect to
the existing quality metrics, like if there's any defined, so that once we develop our system, we can just baseline and compare
How's the whole thing improved or something like this.
Um, and on ours, um, yeah, we'll also, like, set up, uh, one recurring call with all of you guys who just check our calendars and then come up with a slot, and then we'll also
I have to, like, come up with one day where we visit the operator and get to meet the standard of things to understand how the current… how they're working on certain businesses.
I would have just said, I recommend sending the product. Yeah, sure, for sure, that'd be great.
It's both a pleasure to have you on board here. I know it'll be excited, looking forward to working on this project, and uh…
I think, uh, in the end, you know,
You'll get an interesting project.
And, uh, something that hopefully meets your requirements.
And meet your expectation of these subset, so…
We'll see how this works out.
We're also really looking forward to, uh,
kind of what the purpose of the project is more fancy. We're curious what…
Not only this day, but all this seems fine with AI systems. We're also working with.
It's not a silver bullet, but it's something that, uh, helpful.
Well, very good. This is exciting, yes.
I do have a slide back as well. Yeah, sure.
alternative, and be safe over the weekend.
Yeah.
Me too, me too. Go snowboarding on Monday for whether that road is slow that much. Yeah, it's in a new base shooting.
You missed out the December storm, yes.
Were you in the struggle? I just slept before the storm.
But he was in Canada, so… It was pretty bad.
Well, years ago, when they had the super big snow shares,
CMEs are the kind of… they want you to come to school, but the city of Pittsburgh beg them to go to school. They closed the school.
We'll see what happens on Monday.
Yeah, it'll be… it'll be interesting. I think there's some places, like,
that aren't used to snow at all.
Pittsburgh has gotten a little better about it, but like…
you know, DC, if they get a, you know, half an inch of snow, the city closes down, and they're supposed to get…
many inches, so it's gonna be…
It's gonna be interesting.
I was living and staying on the front step yesterday, and…
There was nothing happening, but…
The weather overnight, the weather was, it was very slick, very slippery. Yeah, fantastic.
But we're good. Good to see y'all. Good to see you. Thank you so much.
Yep.
WaySec systems in the world.
Are you still there, Dennis?
That is political. Okay, alright.
Okay, thank you. Thank you.
I would certainly say that after a client meeting, it's always good to have a follow-on with the mentors there, just to say,
what their perspective is on the meeting, if there's anything else that popped up, so…
It's always good for you guys to also kind of have a discussion post-meeting about anything you've heard, or…
Something you'll, uh, you need to follow up on, so…
Uh, we can start with Friday.
It was always good